I have a theory called get in the game
and basically I think if you want to go
play a game you need to to go where it's
played like it's not that confusing or
difficult most people say they want to
make a career change and then they send
out their resume to a bunch of different
sites and they hope that they get a job
and the best way to do it in my opinion
is go where people who are experts in
the field are playing so uh what I did
is I ended up going to a bunch of events
and conferences I went to every finance
and money and wealth and investing
conference and event I could find and as
a student there are a bunch that are
free right so
I don't know I must have gone to 30 of
them 40 of them and most of them nothing
really happened but I learned a few
things I got the right words right
because every industry has the
vernacular you know that in medicine and
um and then one day I went to an event
that I really didn't want to go to it
was like I had a long day of classes and
I was late and then I I ended up going
no matter what um my mom has has a
saying which is um always show up and
then look for the exit so you can go
note the exit at any time time you can
leave but just step your foot in the
door because that's when magic happens
kind of like that line in tolken right
you know it's a it's an amazing thing
what happens or it's a dangerous thing
what happens when you step one foot
outside your door uh that was from The
Hobbit for you nerds like me who like
that olly and I were talking Harry
Potter so I was going to see if I could
be cool like him um so so I went and I
listened to this event and I didn't know
anything about anything but I was
curious as a journalist so I asked a lot
of questions and the woman who sat next
to me ended up being recruiter for a
company called Vanguard which is one of
the largest investors investment firms
in the world and so she because of all
my pester in her I guess thought that
was unique everybody loves to hear their
own voice and uh and so asked me to
interview for their rotational
development program and if you're young
these days everybody tells you to go be
an entrepreneur I actually think you
should do the opposite I think you
should go learn on somebody else's dime
because Vanguard puts in on average
$100,000 worth of training into every
new hire I would never St stay at
Vanguard I didn't like the place uh but
I love starting there because they train
you I got licensed and I got to learn on
somebody else's dime when you come out
of college typically and especially if
you don't go to college I feel like you
have a lot of rough edges you know you
make faux Paws constantly in business
you don't know the language or the
context and going to a corporation I
think actually teaches you a ton so I'm
a big advocate for starting and then go
to your own thing but these days I feel
like everybody wants to be a YouTube
Star right away and you've met a lot of
Young YouTube Stars too half the time
I'm like like you guys couldn't
exist out in the real world for 4
seconds because um you don't have a lot
of context for for what else Works in
this world of ours on that note so the
whole um what to do with your career
when you're when you're young um one
view is if you want to be an
entrepreneur just go straight into it
yeah well another view is if you want to
be an entrepreneur you can learn on
someone else's time um I was
interviewing someone else on the Pod Dan
Priestley and and his view was if you
want to be an entrepreneur uh loar on
someone else's dime but try and get a
job in a company that has fewer than 10
people because if you work for a big
corporate
the you just learn a lot less about the
whole business than you would if you're
working in like a eight-man whatever
team where you actually have visibility
over revenues profits all that kind of
stuff what's your what's your take on
that I I think I'm of two minds one I
don't think there's only one right path
do either I think the smart thing though
is if you can learn on other people's
dime that's really helpful because
you'll never bankrupt yourself while
working a Sal
right and so um that is a really big
Safeguard because what I like to to make
sure people don't do is there's a lot of
like um hustle porn out there right like
sleep on your couch for 47 years and you
know only eat ramen noodles and that's
okay but I'm not sure it's necessary and
I also think it's a dangerous road to
think that way because you know in
America for instance uh people on
average have less than two weeks of cash
on hand so if we're out there telling
people all the time to go risk it all
not every every body makes it so let's
give them like a little buffer you know
and and it's okay to have a little
buffer don't let anybody tell you that
you have to hustle and focus on the one
thing and Gary your V Gary ve your way
to success I don't think you have to
even though I like the guy um so I think
you can do either the the one thing I
liked about the corporate
structure is they they spend they have
so much extra Capital that they can
spend a lot on you you know in startups
me too I have like three dimes to rub
together you know like I don't training
are you like when somebody asks me do I
get training if I come on board I'm like
next company there's no training here um
we're too young we're too small we don't
have time it's like get in do whatever
you can do the other thing about
startups that's dangerous is they grow
so fast if you're at a good one that if
you are not a self grower you will be
quickly outgrown in a startup and so I'm
sure you've experienced it too in most
of my startups we've you know 3x every
year and so if somebody cannot 3x thems
in a year they can't stay in the startup
because we're moving too fast and so you
have to be careful I think if you go to
a startup and you think I'm just going
to like learn a little bit as I go uh-uh
this is like death by fire hose and so
yes you can do the 8 to10 company but if
you're the type of person where you need
a little bit more time and you want to
want to give yourself a bigger barrier
between um you know your ability to have
to level up immediately in a startup
then I I like the corporate route and
I'm not saying it's fun it's awful I
hated working in corporations it's not
fun but just because it's not fun
doesn't mean it's not good hey friend
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye-bye